they will find themselves once again in
a world of Gins and fairies and
intermediary beings you're seeing a lot
of people talk about re-enchantment
people taking mushrooms talking about
all these beings that they meet and
everything and I think that that's the
future if you want to know what the
future is that's it but it's not that
great of a future it's scary because
without order without the logos ordering
that world for us then it's a very scary
and dangerous world to walk through but
I really remember the int experience of
having been a Christian a believing
Christian and then in a very short
period of time entering into what you
might call a re-enchanted
[Music]
world this is Jonathan pedo welcome to
the symbolic
world
so hello everyone this is Sarah from
Hamilton and today I'm very excited to
have Jonathan Pou back on the channel uh
my last video with Jonathan was one of
the most viewed long form videos on this
channel so I know people got a lot out
of it and I definitely did as well so
welcome back it's great to see you again
s always great to talk to you you too so
I want to talk today about a lot of
things really but I'm going to start by
returning to this theme of universal
history which you've produced a huge
amount of content on and I want to
connect that a little bit to your recent
work on Snow White and so let me just
ask you this question what is the
connection between the universal history
of real quote unquote Nations Ethiopia
America Israel uh and uh unreal or or
fictional narratives how do those two
things intersect and what does that mean
for the significance of symbolism in
Universal history well what happens I
think the way to understand is that what
happens with universal history in some
ways is that the way that things are
remembered at the origin especially at
the origin of something they tend to
have a certain form they tend to
contract towards in certain directions
towards something we could call
mythological storytelling which is that
the the the become more and more
condensed and uh you know you
find things that we don't usually find
in everyday life when you look
especially the further you go back into
the past so if you look at early uh
Chronicles it's always like Giants and
dragons and you know hybrid Kings and
all of this stuff that seems a little
crazy to us um and I think that studying
fairy tales can help us understand why
it is that things get remembered that
way and why and what importance they
have some of the images and some of the
tropes have an analogical coherence you
could say that that can help us
understand why our Universal histories
look the way they do um and then to some
extent also why those patterns happen in
scripture as well similar patterns as to
what happened in the fairy tales of
course in scripture we're talking about
a different level of reality we don't
want to comp we don't want to compare
scripture and fairy tales too much but
to some extent we can in the sense that
they
they seem to capture similar themes uh
as the the fairy tale seem to capture
similar themes that what you find
especially in the Old Testament yeah and
what do you mean there's been a recent
um I've noticed uh Focus uh from a lot
of different people on this idea of you
know a haunted universe or a universe
which is more populace than um then then
we're familiar with thinking of it um
and I know reading ST perero it was very
interesting to me there's a story um
where someone is talking to him and he's
asking him uh you know are is there life
on other planets are there aliens and he
says why are you even asking me about
life on other planets do you know just
how much stuff there is around us right
now that you no idea exists and and I
just thought that was so interesting
because St perero is one of those Saints
who has you might say relatively unique
spiritual gift in that he was able to
see um lots of different things in the
material world and the non-material
world which aren't accessible to us or
even to a lot of other Saints um and
that was just fascinating to me in terms
of this new kind of excitement a
relatively new excitement about a more
populous universe so yeah when we talk
about fairy tales obviously we're
talking in part about fairies so do you
think that at what point do we say that
um there is kind of a genuine concrete
reference to beings that we might call
fairies yeah
so let me back up a little bit and try
to I think kind of contextualize what's
happening in terms of this new interest
in like you said a more populous
Universe you know one of the things that
happened of course in 19th century
materialism was the evacuation of agency
in the cosmos uh as Superstition right
the idea that that every time you see
agency in the cosmos or that you see
other Consciousness acting in the cosmos
um it's just Superstition and and
projection you know that's the type of
word they use but that type of thinking
this materialist type of thinking was
never trying didn't come to the point of
trying to account for our Consciousness
and our agency and they were just
ignoring it as this kind of blind spot
from a point of view where they looked
on the world with that agency and
consciousness but then but then use
their reason and their agency and
Consciousness to evacuate the rest of
the universe of agency and Consciousness
and so I think that we've come to a
point where even a lot of scientists and
a lot of you know especially scientists
that study cognition they're realizing
that this is a ridiculous position to
stand in it's a ridiculous position to
ignore the categories of Consciousness
when we're literally using those
categories to evacuate the cosmos of
Consciousness so I think that's the
point where we where we've come to where
now there are people very reasonable you
know people that aren't Christian that
are atheists or secular or all kinds of
people that are willing and in some ways
realize that using categories of agency
and Consciousness to understand certain
phenomena is actually more useful than
the kind of cold analytical description
that that they're used to especially for
understanding social movements for
understanding kind of large scale uh uh
Transformations using things like agency
to explain those you know what people
use the term egregor they use different
you know they use things like emergence
words like emergence in some ways it
doesn't matter to us at the outset what
word they use but they're noticing
something like intelligent patterns kind
of coming back and manifesting
themselves on the world so once you've
crossed that
threshold and this is the the funny
thing that a lot of people don't realize
once they cross that threshold and they
ride that
out uh consistently they will find
themselves once again in a world of Gins
and fairies and and intermediary uh
beings and I think that that you're
seeing a lot of people talk about
re-enchantment you know you have broad
Dreer I've just read an article by Mary
Harrington today that tries to talk
about re-enchantment people taking
mushrooms talking about all these beings
that they meet and everything and I
think that that's the future if you want
to know what the future is that's it but
it's a scary it's not that great of a
future it's scary because without order
without the
logos you know ordering that world for
us then it's a it's a very scary and
dangerous world to walk through so I
think that fairy tales are a way to help
people re accustom themselves with these
types of of of patterns it was really
interesting to me that you just
mentioned the danger of meeting these
things apart from the logos and then
mention Fairy Tales again because I
remember in that ous strength which is
called a modern fairy tale or a fairy
tale for grown-ups That Hideous Strength
has this wonderful scene where um Jane
encounters Venus um and she goes into
her room and she sees this Burning woman
and it absolutely terrifies her and uh
when she goes to Ransom and talks about
it uh he tells her well you've met Venus
but you've met Venus kind of naked
you've met her apart from M or Christ in
the story and I think that idea really
rolls together with a lot of things we
read about in scripture especially I
think in Galatians where the what life
looks like outside of Christ is you are
enslaved or subjected to these Powers
which are external to you you are
considered just as kind of a part of a
kind of wild world whereas in Christ
humanity is really born so that Humanity
stands um you know in relation to the
world as its Lord master and bridegroom
because of the Incarnation of the word
who structures all of these different
things so I know that's a you know no I
think you're you're you're totally right
and you know you can we can talk about
it in different ways especially for
people who might struggle to understand
this because you know obviously when you
say something like that as as you and I
who've been thinking about this forever
it just makes sense when secular people
hear something like that they just hear
woo they just like see the the wildness
and craziness and so you know one of the
things that I've been trying to to do is
obviously to bridge these two worlds
that people understand what the hell
we're talking about and I think that you
know understanding for example virtues
and vices you know it's a it's a
completely traditional Christian way to
help people understand how agency acts
on us and how depending on how we
approach certain agencies that are
acting on us and through us then they
can either be liberating and pointing
towards Christ or they can they can
simultaneously be you know tyrants that
rule over us you know and so if you
think of a of a of of a that they have a
virtue like courage you know that is
that is definitely a virtue if it's
pointed in the right direction if you're
courageous for the right reasons that
but then the same virtue can become a
kind of pride ful you know
irascibility that will then that can
trap you and that can make you a slave
if it's not pointed towards something
higher if it's not pointed to something
it kind of traps you that's what Dante
for example tries to show in his Divine
Comedy which is that you know anything
that is not that not aiming up and
always kind of giving itself up towards
higher and higher Goods can become a
vice and that's what we see in the falia
you know it's like the vices and the
virtues are basically the same thing
that that depending on how they're
treated will will uh will either be
something like a you know Angelic
transport towards God or a demonic kind
of uh rule over you and so this is it's
more than that it's not just virtues
obviously it it is actual agencies that
can rule over you but I think that to
help secular people using the language
of Virtues is a way to to at least help
them see a little bit through this so
they don't think we're just like in a
Marvel Universe with like Gods floating
in the heavens that are just you know
like this kind of weird materialist
Ghostbuster type of spirituality that
people uh you know immediately go
to yeah and and um I think that's a
really good point I want to invite you
all to the very first symbolic World
Summit over 3 days we will finally meet
in real time in real space and everyone
from this little corner of the internet
will be there to explore the theme of
reclaiming the cosmic image of course I
will be speaking but there will also be
Martin Shaw who is an amazing
mythographer
father Steven D young of Lord of spirit
Fame there will be Richard Roland from
the universal history series Vesper
Stamper Nicholas kotar and Neil de gr
that you've all seen on my channel here
and there for entertainment we have
everyone's favorite apocalyptic band The
One and Only dirt po Robins this event
will be the chance of a lifetime to
capture and embrace our current moment
so join us from February 29th to March
2nd 2024 in Tarpon SP Florida visit the
symbolic
world.com Summit for more information
and I will see you
there and part of what has interested me
you know since I mean it's now become
something of a you know a buzzword for
certain people but I really remember the
intense experience of having you know
been a Christian a believing Christian
and then in a very short period of time
entering into what you might call a
re-enchanted world where all of these
things which formerly would have an
intuition of implausibility had exactly
the inverse intuition so that you know
before if I read a typological pattern
in history I would say oh someone's
fudging the details yeah and then
afterwards if I read a typological
pattern in history that's like oh well
this is more likely to be true than not
because this is just the way the world
Works um so what what you just said
there reminded me of one of those
questions that I've had for a long time
which is um in a lot of
circumstances why does the occult quote
unquote seem to work um and let me just
kind of throw a theory at you and then
see what you have to say so my idea
about this if you just think about what
the occult is it works through speech
incantations and you use incantations to
alter and change things so you know God
makes the world through the word you
know he's speaking throughout the six
creation days then he makes Man In His
Image I.E man is the speaking creature
God speaks to man God a man can speak
back to God in other words and then man
reconstitutes and changes the world
through that speech well I think what
the occult is or at least a lot of it
what it really is is it takes that
principle that nature that human beings
are tied to the world in such a way that
their speech will alter and change
things and it severs it from its
archetype the super nature which is the
basis for its existence and so what is
going on in the occult versus what is
going on in Chris Christi prayer well in
a certain way there's an analogy between
the two in that both are trying to
influence the world in one way or
another when I'm praying for someone to
get well you know I'm submitting the
will to God but I am trying to get them
well by the means of prayer and I think
what happens in prayer is we take our
will our intentions our desires and we
seek to affect them in the world but we
always bring them through the crucified
Christ so that we say not my will but
thy will be done and what that does is
it perfects our intentions so that they
can be realized with the maximum
goodness whereas if a person does not
transmit their will through Christ this
is incredibly dangerous because they say
oh I want more money but they don't have
a sufficient understanding of the nature
of what money is and everything else
with which it is connected so that when
they realize their intentions in the
world without transmitting them through
the logos who is the archetype of all
things they get all this other stuff
along with it that they weren't
expecting because they don't have the
comprehensive knowledge of the nature
that the logos himself has so I think
when you look at you know the occult and
the ceremonial nature of it in a certain
way it is a parody of the Liturgy
because the Liturgy is where we rule
over the world that is where we enter
into Christ's throne room and there it
looks like that but even for a person
who doesn't believe in God or Christ
even for people who are interested in
practicing it there's something creepy
about it there's something that's wrong
I mean I think that's CS Lewis talks
about that you know when he was a
younger man interested in the occult not
a Christian something was just off about
it it seems to be detached from its
actual end yeah I think I think your
inside is absolutely right that's what
it is so the way to kind of understand
it is for normal people to think about
this is that the the idea that you use
ritual language and incantation in order
to modify reality is actually something
that you do every day all the time right
it's like if I if I ask my contractor
and I signed a contract with my
contractor to build my house I'm using
language meaning and ritual in order to
get my house built and so I'm not
building my house right someone else is
doing my will for me through through
through an incantation and uh and a
ritual signing of a document so that the
contractor will then build my will my
house for me right so it's something
that we actually do all the time so
first of all we have to be a little
cautious about freaking out too much
like about some of this stuff right but
we should freak out because the
difference between me asking getting
signing a contract with my contractor to
build my house and an occultist is that
the occultist is
conscious spiritually conscious of the
mechanisms by which things manifest
themselves in the world he understands
that you are invoking certain principle
IP alties and certain realities in order
to get things done in the world but they
are trying to utterly weaponize
spiritual principles in order to get
their will to be done by ignoring the
way in which it connects to the highest
good and to to to to God right and so
the truth is
that sometimes I'm doing that all the
time in my life now right it's like I'm
sinning all the time because I'm hungry
and I want to eat and so I'll ask my son
to go to the store and get me a
chocolate bar or whatever and in that
way I'm doing all that stuff but it's
it's kind of unconscious it's it's not
it's not great but it's it's it's kind
of unconscious but when you become
conscious of it then the sin becomes
much greater because you know what
you're doing you know what type of
action you're posing and what what type
of let's say misdirected power that
you're using in order to accomplish your
goals and that's why like you said
that's why it ends up looking more
ritualized that's why it ends end up
being more like liturgy because it's
people that are more aware of the
mechanisms of reality and because of
that should be more let's say more aware
of how they should ultimately you know
participate in a in a true liturgy which
is submitting their will to God and then
through that you know submitting their
will and the wills of things around them
to God so that God's God's will can
transform everything uh but but it's
hard it's hard because people to think
like well how why would that work like
why would you know saying some
incantation uh why would you know doing
some procession work and it's only
because they don't understand that they
do it all the time and just because they
can they can recognize the mechanical
causes that is bringing about the change
that somehow now they they believe in it
but but you know when a when a
politician let's say makes a kind of
statement on television about what needs
to happen
you know or or or some kind of thought
leader and then it happens in the world
they are not aware of the mechanical
causes by which it's happening they
don't they don't know who's going to
instantiate it or who's going to make it
happen but it still changes the world
and so it's those types of
understandings that the occultists are
trying to weaponize towards their will
and in some in a stranger way and in a
more subtle way it's something similar
to that that we understand that if we
address our prayer to God and we submit
our will to God then the greatest
transformation for the greatest good is
happening as we're doing
that so what do you think of uh of the
global Consciousness project I don't
know what that is what's the global
Consciousness project Global
Consciousness project sounds Eerie to
me it's it's so it's been a while since
I've looked at it but what it is is they
um set up around the world true random
number number generators which are
really actually hard to do because
getting genuine Randomness and not just
a really complicated pattern uh takes a
lot of doing a lot of computer power and
so they set up these random number
generators around the world and it's
going to just Generate random numbers
obviously and then what they do is they
look for patterns in it and they see if
that's correlated with major events in
um you know world affairs and so in like
massive divination project here yeah so
they what they did is they I think it's
was set up in the 9s and then they uh
just looked at the data set in like
September 11th 2001 and uh they argued
that the numbers become less and less
random because there's a genuine kind of
physical significance to human attention
being focused at the same thing in other
words that reconstitutes the actual
structure of the world in some
mysterious with Rel ative to our present
state of knowledge uh way so assuming uh
for my viewers it's been a while since
I've looked at this I'm not going on in
on the legitimacy of this but assuming
that that data set is actually true how
would you interpret that in light of
what we were just saying yeah I think
there are two things like like
divination is obviously is GNA say
Obviously well I it's obviously a real
thing divination is practice in every
culture all the time from the beginning
of time there's I don't think there's
such a thing as a culture that doesn't
have some form of divination even within
the Bible there are there's divination
the the the famous Ur and thumim you
know there they were divination uh
things you have Joseph who has a cup for
divination that he hides in his
brother's uh bag and you know even in
the New Testament you have the discip
the the apostles drawing Lots in order
to decide who the next the next Apostle
is going to be these are divination
these are div divination
mechanisms
now I think you're right and and the
idea is that there's a there's a
relationship between intention and
question as a frame right you you can
understand it that way it's like you're
framing reality you're looking at
reality for a reason and when you look
at reality for a reason then out of
indefinite potential right out of the
the chaos tohubohu chaos that is still I
think believe underlying all of real
you know forms will will come up because
it's like it's it's it's analogous to
When God Says calls forth and says to
the Earth bring forth you know
identities and then then he sees them
and then and then you know man
participates in naming them so I think
that's that's actually how it works
now there are obviously also reasons why
divination is is prohibited in Scripture
because because it is very it is
dangerous the question is why are you
doing that that's I think that's the
biggest question it's like why are you
doing that are you doing that because
you want to try to if you're doing that
because you want to try to predict the
future in the kind of Base way if you're
doing that usually people do that stuff
because they want to get rich really
like you know they they they want to
guess the numbers for the lottery or
some kind of nonsense like that and so
you can understand that when humans look
for that type of power they're often
doing it for for they're more than often
you know just doing it for the wrong
reasons and also the other problem I
think is
that the the capacity to accumulate data
sets and to notice patterns across
across massive amounts of let's say
generated chaos uh doesn't mean that
you'll understand them the insight to
understand those and the insight to
understand the the the meaning from them
don't come from that from that
generation they come from heaven you
could say and you know the capacity to
interpret dreams you could say that you
see in in in Joseph is similar to that
but just because you have the dream
doesn't mean you can interpret it and
sometimes people will will put their
will like you when we talked about the
idea of occultism instead of being a
transparent vehicle for a higher
Identity or or or reality to manifest
itself then they'll just put their will
in it and then it gets twisted right
away into whatever it is that they want
right so what you're were saying reminds
me of um uh that phrase in Genesis 11
where mankind they come together they
build a city a culture and a tower cult
and they're all unified and God says
they're all one people nothing that they
do will be impossible for them and I
think people read that and they're like
well isn't God God I mean uh what is he
talking about here but I think this is
actually a real statement of the
ontology of creation mankind exists and
in Genesis 1 there's one image of God it
is the Human family male and female who
is the image of God so when mankind is
United that is the image through which
God develops the world and so when
mankind is joined together and is of one
mind but that one mind is directed
contrary to the word that is an
existential threat to the Integrity of
creation so that in the flood the world
just collapses it falls apart um and
I think that says something but let me
just get on what you said which is that
it's a great it's a great like nothing
will stop them from doing what they want
to do and and and and that's true and
like you said it's you you got it
exactly right which is that the problem
like what you when we talked about
occultism at the outset the problem is
that is that you don't understand what
it is that you want you don't understand
all the cories of what it is that you
want so maybe we will create a society
where everybody has everything they need
physically and everybody's super
comfortable and then we're like well why
is everybody infertile now why does
everybody why is everybody desperate why
is everybody miserable didn't we do what
we wanted to do and I think that that's
right it's like it's exactly right so
the story story of bab is like they'll
do what they want to do but it's
actually to their own
destruction yeah so um let me just kind
of take that and ask over the past
couple years or few years um in what way
has your kind of attention to
symbolism in creation and in
non-biblical quote unquote stories how
has that affected your reading of
scripture and then how did they kind of
ping back and forth because that's been
a big thing for me that reading
symbolism in scripture then you see the
world better and then you see scripture
better so on and so forth oh definitely
I mean I think that you know if you
think think if you take the Snow White
project that we're doing now that is
definitely there's been this weird back
and forth between scripture and so let
me give you a little
example in Snow White it is you know
snow white eats an apple and dies right
so you're like obviously there's got to
be a connection to the other story but
it's kind of Muddy right it's like I
don't totally see it and then I realized
that in the story of Snow White uh in
the original Grim story or you know
based on the ancient Traditions the the
queen goes TW three times to see her and
every time she goes she brings her
something to supplement her beauty she
brings her a comb and then like a a
girdle or a belt in order to
supplementary Beauty and you're like why
is she doing that isn't Snow White the
most beautiful girl in the world so why
is she trying to tempt her with this
supplementarity and then I'm like okay
I'm on to something this is definitely
what's going on related to scripture and
so then my my Insight was that in fact
what the what the queen is offering Snow
White with the apple is awareness of
beauty she saying you will know that you
are the most beautiful in the
world she already is the most beautiful
in the world but you'll know that you're
the most beautiful and so she trades
like reality for the supplement for the
artifact of it or for the the
self-conscious awareness of it and she
and she actually trades the real thing
for that and I thought oh man
there's already there's something in
Genesis going on with that because it
says that Adam and Eve are made in the
image of
God and then this the serpent says eat
the fruit and you'll become like
God it's like there's something so it's
like I'm still I'm still kind of
bouncing off those two those two those
two things and then Snow White brought
me back to scripture and made me notice
that it's as
if it's as if there's something that you
know the idea that what God really did
want for them was them to become like
him that's actually what he wants for
them but that in taking that for
themselves and becoming kind of becoming
self-aware of it through an an act of
Will and power they lose it but if they
had just submitted to God and you know
been in the right relationship to him
then they would have been they they
would have accomplished that which is
that ultimately even because they even
what the serpent promised them they
could have they would have accomplished
it and that's what we see in Christ
obviously uh uh and so it's weird that
so Snow White so it's like I I use the
Bible to understand Snow White but then
when I saw what happening was happening
in Snow White it made me see back in
scripture a pattern that I had kind of
skipped over that IID you know ironed
over too
easily that when you're describing that
story it recalled for me you know this
great biblical theme which is that you
know after the sin one of the curses is
that your desire will be after your
husband now you know in the context of
the story Adam has already been created
in a relationship to Eve which can be
called headship and so how exactly do we
take that what the way I've come to take
it to say well right now what Adam is
what's happened made Adam a fallen
creature and Eve the feminine partner is
now in a state of curse because she's in
subjection to this creature who is
fallen and so then you see throughout
Isaiah and so forth Zion is described as
a bride who is Barren who can't bring
forth seed and the servant and the god
of Israel so hint hint they're both
described as the true bridegroom who is
going to marry this barren woman and
raise her from the dead and so there's
that that theme in a lot of stories you
know that the bride is in a state uh to
some degree of her own fault to some
degree not of her own fault it's a
complex issue in scripture uh the bride
is in this state of deep sleep or death
and needs rescuing from the bridegroom
and obviously this is typical of Christ
um and then in that theme of
knowledge uh I think we see there's a
lot of stuff going on in Genesis 3 and
following and then in the New Testament
because they eat of the tree of
knowledge of Good and Evil and then
Genesis 4 Adam knew his wife and she
conceived and she brought forth Cain so
what is the problem here well the
problem is that Adam and Eve have just
been cut off from the presence of God
and the presence of God in the garden is
the means by which their knowledge is
joined to him and having been cut off
from the presence of God they know each
other to some degree apart from uh God
and that produces Generations which lead
down to the flood and then in the New
Testament what happens is we have a mode
of selfhood that is from outside this
world but comes into this world that is
the sell foood of the only begotten son
in relation to the father and that
enables us to then be human in a way
that um is compatible with God's knowing
us fully so that we might be fully known
so those are just some yeah yeah yeah
there there's definitely there's
definitely that's definitely right and
the the we the strangeness of the story
too the strangeness of the story when
you see this how Christ kind of resolves
the whole pattern
um it's it's a it's interesting when you
compare to Adam and Eve and you see you
know what knowledge does and how Christ
reacts
to um to his situation
and how Adam reacts to situation and so
I always have this image where you know
the
the the serpent the the serpent tells
Adam and Eve if you eat the fruit you'll
become like God and then God told Adam
and Eve if you eat the fruit you will
die and Jesus just said yes like yes to
both those you know and but Adam didn't
and that was that was in some ways part
of the Fall is that Adam refuses to
Humble himself you know in the in the
moment where he eats he refuses to die
in the moment when he eats the fruit he
says it's not my fault it's her fault
it's not my fault it's the Serpent's
fault it's like it's everybody's fault
but mine and I'm going to protect myself
gonna hide myself I'm going to to cut
myself off from God whereas Christ says
yes and then Christ dies and and you
know and so this image you know you you
you Orthodox so you've seen it like this
kind of this icon that we have during
during uh Holy Week of the bridegroom
you know and it's like we have this this
icon which we call the icon of the
bridegroom and it's the icon of Christ
being beaten and tortured you know and
ironically being treated as King by by
pilate and his and his his cronies uh
and it's like well that's the surprise
that's the surprise of the bridegroom
right it's the surprise of what it is
that solves the puzzle from the
beginning which is that in humbling our
ourselves in being willing to die you
know then that knowledge is transformed
into Glory it doesn't cut us off it
actually leads us higher
into yeah into into the highest place so
it's a it's yeah blose your mind when
you when you see it yeah in Genesis you
know when God says if you eat of this
fruit in the day you eat of it you shall
surely die you know one of the things
that happens immediately afterwards is
God takes Adam puts him into a deep
sleep which is would argue a type of
death you know it's a place where you're
divided in two and then you're reunited
in glorified form and then when you
think about the way in which Christ is
the bridegroom and the way that that
connects to his mission relative to the
church by the way for my audience I do
live near a military based if you can
hear the the plane outside so I
apologize for that uh if you think about
the way that Christ is bridegroom to his
church it says that he cleansed her by
the washing of water through the word
and then you read Genesis 3 and there's
supposed to be a three-way dialogue here
or a trialog the serpent Eve and Adam
because it says Adam was with her and
yet he's utterly silent the serpent is
engaging in this dialogue with Eve and
Adam is just kind of standing there and
I think one of the implications of the
text is that Adam is very interested to
see what is going to happen because God
has told him something about the tree
the day you eat of it you will surely
die but he hasn't learned that by direct
experience and now he has this other
person who's standing there and the
serpent is saying you're not going to
die why didn't you eat of it and Adam
stands there he waits sees she eats of
it he doesn't immediately drop dead and
then Adam says I'm going to eat of it as
well and then it's the divine presence
which comes and and James Jordan has
argued that this is the first instance
in scripture of the delay of the peras
where the divine presence waits for us
to kind of work our own will out before
appearing and then um implementing the
consequences of that decision so there's
so much stuff here that I think you're
right in that going to these
mythological or fictional stories these
fairy tales you know we're less familiar
with them and as a
consequence sometimes the point of the
story strikes us more directly and then
we read scriptural stories with which we
are more familiar and we see them in in
a new and more profound light
that's that's absolutely right and I see
that all the time where
people we know we've been so especially
if you grew up in a Christian world and
if you you're surrounded by these
Christian stories these stories are so M
are have become almost invisible because
people know them and they don't see
their full implications they don't see
and also because of the way the
scripture is written you know the links
aren't often made for you like they
would in a movie for example like you
watch a movie and it's you know it's
like they'll lead you along they'll make
sure you understand how everything
connects to everything else and that's
fine it's like a training for for
stories but in scripture it's not like
that in scripture it's just like Event
Event Event Event Event and and you have
to be able to see the pattern through it
they're not going to tell you they're
not going to hint at it uh and so and so
looking at these looking at ancient
myths or looking at fairy tales even
what even modern fa storytelling can be
a training for us uh because they have
to some way maintain similar patterns
because they're made of attention you
know stories are made of attention
they're the things we care about and and
we are created by God we're created by
the Divine logos and so when we when we
are attracted to something even if it's
perverse like I'm not saying that
everything we're attracted to is good
obviously sometimes it's bad but hidden
behind that is always something which is
revealing reality to you which is why
even when you're you're attracted to
something that makes you sin in that sin
there's always an opportunity right
there's always like an opening where
you're like oh no like why did I do that
why did I pay attention to that why did
I like why did I move down that road and
there's an opportunity to actually see
God like you talked about this idea of
of the divine presence manifesting
itself I think that happens almost every
time you sin that happens it's like you
sin and then you're like and then then
you can feel the burning or like this
presence of God that's reminding you of
of how of how you misdirected your your
will and your attention yeah and that's
that is something which you know is it's
a way in which I think God works out all
our evil intentions for good and you
know we talked about That Hideous
Strength a little bit earlier there's
this part in That Hideous Strength where
Jane is with Ransom she's with the good
guys and she's learning the forms of
things by direct acquaintance with their
goodness so they're coming the forms of
the or the archons of the plan planets
are coming and revealing themselves and
she is becoming acquainted through that
with God and at the same time her
husband from whom she's been separated
is learning the same goodness because
he's drawn into the objective room where
the bad guys systematically pervert even
the most mundane of things so there's a
a set of dots which seem to be forming a
pattern and yet they're not quite
forming a pattern there's beautiful art
which has ugliness just stuck on top of
it and the mundane nature of the evil is
meant to lead Mark to see that the only
thing there is is evil lack of pattern
but he actually it says in in the story
Lewis says in that moment through seeing
the perversions of these things Mark
came to be conscious in a way that he
never was before that if there's a bent
there must be a straight yeah so you
know God wants to teach us of his own
goodness by acquaintance with the
goodness
but in Divine Providence when we sin we
can also learn of goodness after we sin
by repentance because we taste the bad
and then God says repent we turn back
and we see it by contrast and then yeah
that habituates us to seek the good
before we seek the bad yeah that's
absolutely right and you see that
happening all around us right now which
is that you know certain forces are
trying to twist reality into Fantastical
shapes and into upside down shapes you
know the
upside down patterns and what It
ultimately will do is restore truth you
know it'll be a painful Road for that to
happen it's painful and it's G to it's
not it's going to get worse folks every
I think most people know that by now
things are going to get worse things are
going to get crazier you know the
carnival is going to increase and the
and the clowns are going to rule but you
know when you you when you sadly are
faced with a Clown King then all it does
is remind you of what is true like it
because it's it's painful and it's
ridiculous and so it's actually secretly
shining a light on the true nature of of
of of kingship of like the Return of the
King ultimately in the end uh but but I
think so at least we can you know that's
why I always say I'm a short-term
pessimist but I'm a long-term
Optimist yeah yeah absolutely and I
think one of the things I've seen over
the past several years is that um
people's I don't know how exactly to put
it but their plausibility structure has
kind of been broken down because people
have been disillusioned by you know we
might call it the establishment the
intellectual establishment they say wait
a second a lot of this stuff is really
really bizarre I don't buy it as a
consequence a lot of people I think have
really been attracted to things which
are genuinely silly but by the same
principle a lot of people have been
attracted to what is not genuinely silly
but before they would have thought it's
genuinely silly I.E Christianity yeah um
and the breaking down of the
plausibility structure you know it's a
crisis and an opportunity it's a crisis
because people can embrace the genuinely
nutty stuff which is going to be bad for
them spiritually and intellectually but
they can also embrace the true nuttiness
uh which is the foolishness of God
revealed in the Cross of Christ and I've
seen um that latter Point happen in
people I never would have expected um it
to happen to and and I just find that
super super um exciting so well it is
it's an exciting time it's a wild and
exciting time and I think that you know
the I hate making actual prediction but
I think I do think that what we're going
to see is while the world is getting
crazier and crazier and as people accept
things that you know we would have
thought was impossible you know uh just
20 years ago that people would accept it
as they as this kind of becomes as this
Insanity becomes mainstream we're going
to see a little Arc you know that's
going to start to become more and more
uh that's going to congregate you could
say you know in in in Christianity we're
going to see very intelligent conscious
people that are going to become
Christian and it's going to be it's
always going to be a minority but it's
going to be a very strong and and Lucid
minority amongst the the kind of
increasing Madness so I think that's
something we can hope for and it's
something that we can also find joy in
like you said because you know I'm
seeing amazing
people that are that I that I never
would have thought also would become
Christian and Orthodox and are
converting and I hear wild things like I
meet I meet people that I haven't talked
to in years and they're like oh yeah and
it's just normal for them to go to
church when just five years ago they
were absolute atheists and completely
and so so it is a time I mean it's a
time to weep because things are getting
crazy but I think there's also there's
also place for rejoicing as well yeah
yeah
so in all in light of all
this what would you say to a person who
is kind of in the midst of the kind of
collapse of the plausibility structure
they don't know what to believe and it
it I think it's kind of scary you know
suddenly you have no categories with
which to assess reality you have no way
of differentiating what's nonsensical
from what's actually legitimate so let's
say that that person comes to you
they're in a state of
Crisis uh they ask you why Christ what
is your answer to
them like Christ
well so I mean I think that the
Incarnation becomes the key to
reestablishing a a a structure of
reality you know because you want you
realize and in fact reality isn't just a
bunch of facts that reality has to be
framed that reality reality has has to
be anchored in purpose and so once you
once you notice that especially as you
see the Things Fall Apart you know and
you see that if they're not anchored in
purpose then they go astray and they
become insane and tyrannical and and mad
the question of what it is that is the
highest anchor becomes a plausible
question to
answer a plausible question to ask which
is that now that you see that the world
has to be anchored in purpose what is
the highest purpose what is the one
purpose that cannot be uh weaponized
that cannot become a a tyrant or a you
know a kind of demon ruling over you and
you know I think that we can argue that
self-sacrificial love is the one there
is really
nothing if you if you work it through in
your mind all the other virtues all the
other things can become can become
torturous and and and horrible but the
the relationship of the king that gives
himself to others that's it like that's
the key that's the top of the hierarchy
right the top of the hierarchy is not
the king that just rules on others it's
the king that rules and gives himself
simultaneously it's like you can't beat
that story you can't go any higher and
that is the story of the Cross you know
and so you could say well I like it I
kind of believe in it but I don't like
that it's this actual person that was
born 2,000 years ago that revealed this
to us and and and brought us to
participate in that well you're G to you
can run around in circles as as much as
you want but that's the way that's where
it happened and that's where it was
revealed to us and that's the story that
we can participate in you know truly
when you engage into the community the
body that was born out of that out of
that reality um and so so that's why I
think I think that it's you know
ultimately and and ultimately what
happens too what interesting is that
even as the World falls apart and
there's still a remainder of these goods
and a remain and the tort virtuous
version of the virtues that used to
guide us um when people strip them and
start to look at them they'll they'll
realize that it's always Christ hiding
behind there you know as you kind of
straighten it and you remove the
parasitic aspect of these different
values that people are are worshiping
right now you'll realize that it's it's
Christ that's hiding behind it yeah yeah
and and my brother uh my younger brother
he became U when he was a teenager kind
of and what I would call an unhappy
agnostic for some time and it was really
exciting to me to watch him gradually
then come to say wait I think God is
real it was a genuine um intellectual
and spiritual struggle that I think he
handled very responsibly you know and
not jumping into anything trying to
think through all the issues and then I
remember one day that he said I believe
Christ is Lord and it's because you know
he looked at history and as you look at
history it really does seem that there
is a center to it and that Christ really
is at the hearts of we can call it the
human story every human story and when
you look it's and this this struck me
when I was working through my crisis of
Faith which is that how is it that this
obscure Jew is crucified in the first
century a tiny little group of people
announce he's lord of the world and say
by the way he's going to Reign Over All
Nations before they're more than a
little cult and three centuries later
the Roman Emperor is abolishing
sacrifice yeah that's an extraordinary
thing and for me it I I I sometimes
engage in apologetics relative to to
Judaism who argue Jesus is not the
Messiah from script RT and they say Well
when the Messiah comes it'll be obvious
because you'll look outside and people
will be worshiping the god of Abraham
and they say well look out your window
around Passover ceas and then look at
thousands of Gentiles making a
pilgrimage to Jerusalem to honor the god
of Abraham Isaac and Jacob in the name
of the crucified Jew that's an
extraordinary thing you know that alone
does not prove he's the Messiah but it
does put him to the top of the list in
plausibility candidates uh uh and so
yeah well I always used to think I used
I used to have this at some point I
realized because people because it's
also because I grew up Evangelical which
which somehow obscured some of this to
me because you know I grew in the
Evangelical Church there's this idea
that it's it's a it's a
self-contradictory idea because they
believe in everything in the in the
Creed but then they also think
Constantine is the devil and that the
conversion of Rome is the beginning is
the fall of Christianity right it's like
woo uh you know but then when I actually
realized
that Christ you know the idea that
Christ would become his King and that he
would that he would rule over the rule
over the Gentiles it's like well that
happened I mean it took 300 years but it
still happened and when you read what St
Paul's saying it's like St Paul knew it
was happening where St Paul says he is
at this time Christ is ascending the
principalities he's he's subjugating all
these principalities to him it's like
you might not see the fruits of that yet
but just wait you know and so and then
it happened so it's a it's a pretty
astounding it's a pretty astounding
thing and and you're right I I do also
think that you know C there is no way to
view history outside of Christ anymore
you just can't you can't view the world
outside of what Christ came to reveal
and you know even as we move towards
weird internationalism and globalism you
know a lot of the basic values that
underly that even though they become
Twisted you know it it is a kind of the
idea that you should have compassion for
your enemies the idea that you should
all this kind of weird stuff like even
like the rules of war and all that stuff
what would you think that that's just
normal you think it's normal that we
would have rules of engagement and rules
of war and that you wouldn't just
Slaughter your enemies pretend you know
and then just Slaughter your enemies
like if you if you believe in these in
these these values and the idea of
helping the weak and the marginal like
this is all Christian stuff guys I don't
know what to say yeah I I you know
sometimes we can get kind of we can roll
our eyes at you know this or that uh
religious leader generic says war is bad
you're like well yeah of course war is
bad and then I realized one day that is
not something that everybody has taken
for granted there's a reason the cult of
war is Central to lots and lots of
cultures no war julus Caesar so this is
the thing about Christianity too it's
like Christianity is ripe with war and
horrible and tragedy and everything the
difference is they always have to make
excuses for it they have to try to hide
it they have to deny it you might think
that's nothing but Julius Caesar bragged
that he slaughtered a mill million GS
like it was glory to him it wasn't
something that he had to hide or
apologize for or like sweep under the
carpet or try to find some excuse for
it's like no it's like when when you
know when Americans bomb n you know
Hiroshima and Nagasaki they they have to
find some moral twisty reason to like
make that plausible they can't just do
it with a and I and I first of all I
think it's a it's a horrible thing that
happened you know but but the after that
they have to make excuses for it they
can't just be like you know what this is
how we win a war this is how we beat our
enemies and just like you know let's say
uh just just Rebel in the blood of your
enemies like the Scandinavians did it's
like you think any it's just weird to
realize just how people don't can't see
how much you know Christ has transformed
reality yeah yeah absolutely and I think
that connects to this theme you see in
in scripture and outside of scripture
of um you know lurgical
Warfare and it's interesting to me that
so many cultures have a story of
creation through Warfare and then you
read Genesis and you know you've got God
forming filling brightening the world in
these six creation days and then he
enters into his rest but you follow the
language of rest through scripture it's
also used in relation to Warfare so
there seems to be I think some
connection some thematic connection
between what's going on in Genesis and
the bro idea of warfare but the way in
which Christ takes it is that you know
these cultures say Warfare upholds the
world blood is what keeps the world
pumping and Christ says yes it is what
keeps the world pumping it's my blood my
blood that's right and and and I think
that has really profound implications
for what the church's mission is in
relation to her liturgy and that you
know in scripture you know you've got
the idea of the Heavenly Court the
heaven Council you follow that theme
through though you realize the Heavenly
court is God's Heavenly Temple and
that's where liturgy is going on so
Christ is King and priest he's King
because he's priest and priest because
he's King and God is ruling the world
through the Heavenly liturgy and then
you go to the Orthodox liturgy why is it
that we are praying for you know
everything conceivable we're praying for
fruit we're praying for you know that
the Nations be at peace the unity of all
mankind and then we have all these names
we're putting these names into the
Eucharist well this because the liturgy
is the throne room of God this is where
we enter into God's Reign Over the world
and I think we really need to and I say
this to myself as much as to anyone else
um recover the sense that no this is
actually something real there is
ontological significance to writing a
person's name in the diptic and having
them prayed for it changes things when
we do this God really does take that
into the logo so that that he's shaping
the world in and through um his Union
with those those intentions um so I know
that's you know spaghetti but you're AB
you're you're you're absolutely
right uh it's difficult like I find it
hard like I I'll be honest with you like
I struggle to totally believe that you
know but I know it when I stop and I
look at
how how it happens for me like let's
just say like if I carry someone's name
in my heart
that transforms everything about them
right it transforms you know if I if I'm
angry with someone and I'm annoyed with
them and I say okay I'm just gonna carry
that person's name in my in my heart
with good intention I will direct good
intention towards that person then it
changes everything you know and it will
transform my perception of them it'll
transform my actions towards them he'll
transform everything and so it's like
that's actually how it works and so then
the idea that we would take the these
names and that we would raise them up
higher into the Divine will and into the
Divine uh into Divine Providence then of
course it would do the same at a cosmic
level I don't it just makes sense
because we know that that's what happens
within us it's just it's harder because
we're selfish and we're we think we're
little Gods so we think it pretty much
ends with us you know and and that
happens to me all the time uh you know
and I forget to pray for people
constantly you know people ask me to
pray for them and I usually do it for a
few weeks and I forget and it's like man
you know it's like if I like you said if
I
understood the power of taking people's
names and and you know and and and
bringing them up into the throne room of
God I would uh yeah probably be have
more perseverance yeah yeah so so how
has um your kind of focus on symbolism
and all of this stuff how has that if I
can ask it this way shaped the way in
which you read the story of your own
life not to make you sound
self-important or something like that
but are you comfortable um I I suppose
reading the story of your own life
symbolically I think so I but I think we
I think it's dangerous we have to be a
little careful you know the way that I
do it is I try not to be too deliberate
about it uh like you said not to become
not to become self-absorbed but I'm
grateful for the insights that come to
me maybe I would say it that way it's
like there are moments when I see
parallels in the things that I'm doing
and the things that are happening to me
and I see the parallels with scripture
sometimes it's not sometimes it's
frightful it sometimes it's actually
quite frightful but nonetheless I try to
be grateful when I see that that uh that
that uh when I can see the relationship
between these stories but I would be I
would warn people to be careful because
when you become and I say this like
really because the you know I've seen it
happen to many people where when they
start to think this way then they become
the equivalent of paranoid because what
happens is that they become very
self-conscious and they start to analyze
all the things that are happening to
them and all the things that they're
doing in these symbolic structures and
then all of a sudden you know before
they know it they think that they're
being spied on by you know the
Illuminati and that they're you know and
that you know they're demons that are
constantly pulling at them this and that
direction that's why this is happening
and this is happening because of this
and you know it's like if something bad
happens to them then all of a sudden
they're trying to wonder if there's
someone casting a spell on them you know
that kind of stuff that is a very
dangerous place to find yourself in I
think which is why I think the best way
to do it is to focus on God and on the
stories of scripture on the Liturgy on
participating on your family on all the
things that you you can have power on
and not focus on your own story so much
but then once in a while there'll be you
will encounter some insight and and then
you can try to be grateful that that God
is using you in this way or that you
know that God is shining a light on on
moments in your life but I I wouldn't
warn against doing that too much like
for those reasons yeah yeah I mean the
primary reality has got to be you know
our direct
relationship understood not to exclude
our relationship with the church and so
on forth uh our direct relationship with
God and obedience to him and that
obedience precedes wisdom obedience
precedes knowledge if you don't have
obedience you might get like Adam did
knowledge but because knowledge is
ultimately rooted in God and we are
smaller than God if we try to get that
knowledge directly we're going to burst
we're going to burst open and that's why
I think there's there's there's a
connection there with the way we talk
about the mother of God as the kind of
archetype of the church uh Mother of God
is more spacious than the heavens it is
only when God grows us to a sufficient
size that we have the room to actually
assimilate any knowledge and the person
who has grown to that size is a person
who like her is defined by trust and
obedience to his will um you know one of
the things also that I think is because
it's interesting because what that using
the mother God's an example is a really
good one because it says in know when
this is one of my favorites page about
the mother of God which is that you know
when the when the the the Mages come to
see her it says that she gathered all
these things in her heart uh and I love
that because it's like first of all
that's symbolism the word is actually
symbol it's actually symbolism uh where
she kind of gathers all these facts into
her heart and she is basically like you
get the sense that what she's starting
to see the pattern like she sees it's
like oh this is showing this is
manifesting something you know but
there's a kind of a there's a kind of
attentiveness uh that is balanced by you
know her discretion you could say about
it right it's like she didn't start
talking about it she didn't start
telling everybody about what's happening
she just she's kind of gathered these
these hints and these these events into
into her heart and meditating on them I
think that's that's the best approach
you know yeah yeah and in Luke and acts
it's really cool there's 's a there
really is an incredibly developed Mary
Church typology there uh you know one
way to see it is you know the Holy
Spirit overshadowing Mary and then the
Holy Spirit coming on the Apostles of
Pentecost while Mary is said to be there
it's described in the same ways but also
when says she treasured up all these
things in her heart and Jesus will later
say where your heart is there your
treasure is also and then in Acts
there's this emphasis on the church is
of one heart and one mind and they held
all of their wealth together in common
and there's this idea that well what is
wealth really we we we think of wealth
we're used to think of wealth as a tool
to make you comfortable but what's the
difference between $1 billion and $50
billion as far as comfort goes you're
getting diminishing returns that's right
what what is wealth really what wealth
is I think is it represents the degree
to which you can realize you know your
intentions for the world outside of
yourself right with $50 billion doar you
can directly shape and change a lot of
things and I think when scripture
connects wealth to Divine Life you know
the riches of God's glory the idea is
that in Christ we have received reive
the treasury of God's own life we would
say in Orthodoxy his energies his
operations into ourselves and then it is
really the church at prayer which is the
treasury of God's glory in the world we
are then taking that and directing it to
shape and mold certain things which goes
back to what we were just talking about
with the Liturgy and then you look
through the Bible and there's really a
huge amount of financial language in
scripture you know buy without money I
advise you to buy from me gold refined
by fire there's all that stuff there and
and thinking of the the toos say more
spacious than the Heavens to has this
immense treasury who is Christ himself
in her is a good way of of of conceiving
that I think um the other thing that I
think can be difficult or problematic in
quote unquote reading your own life
symbolically is that people can and I I
include myself in this if you see
certain symbolic structures that really
seem to be there there's a kind of
self-importance I I'm the center of
History look at how God is directing my
life you know I might as well be a
Biblical character but I think what you
you always have to remind yourself of is
no this doesn't mean that you're
different from everyone else it means
you're like everyone else where those
symbolic structures are really there
because you read so uh names and uh
lifespans in the Bible often have
symbolic significance people Joseph dies
at 110 years old that a symbolic
significance Moses dies at 120 years old
has symbolic significance the names even
where the meaning is not explicitly
drawn out it really does seem to
correspond to something about their life
I think that's that's true I really
think that is true in principle for
everyone's life even if we don't um know
what it is I think in the final
accounting of things we're going to see
some symbolic meaning to all this stuff
one of the things that that um was very
striking for me in my personal life um
and I'm have her on to talk about all of
this but when I was uh 1819 I did a
40-day aathy to St Nicholas to find an
orthodox spouse okay and it just so
happened that the day of my engagement
and I did not plan this was precisely
4,000 days after I completed that 40-day
set of aathy and I think you know if you
just look at a lot of stories in a lot
of people's lives and a lot of stories
in what are you married now yeah oh
congrat congratulations thank you thank
you yeah so we got married in on on June
glory to God yeah glory to God glory to
God um so seeing that in in my life um I
think what we need to do is we we take
these things as a sign of the way the
world always works not a sign that we
are set apart or special or something
like that yeah that's a good that's a
good way to to to talk about it it's a
good call because like you said like we
we've been saying since the beginning in
some ways those the patterns the the
patterns in scripture are the patterns
that inform reality they are the
patterns that make reality real and they
make and so when we see them we actually
shouldn't be surprised you know and when
and if we see them you know only
occasionally it's it's actually a
reproach on us that we're blind to how
in fact God is always working through
through things and is always you know
bringing things together towards their
good
so yeah and and you know one of those
things that um when I was kind kind of
still going through many years ago you
know doubts about Christianity one of
the things that struck me was you know
there's all these patterns in scripture
you know and the Book of Kings or Exodus
for example you know the temple was
built 480 years exactly 12 * 40 after
The Exodus and well that seems a little
too perfect but then you come into that
period of History which is close enough
to us and we'll documented enough
relative to us that we can say okay no
these the these numbers are real is one
of the things that struck me is wait a
second the temple was destroyed 40 years
after the death and resurrection of
Christ and that little fact kind of
wormed its way into me because it
suggested that these patterns are not
just literary they are a real feature of
the world so that's been just one of the
exciting things I've followed through um
over the last 10 years so we don't have
that much time left but I did want to
just um ask how does
um your project of um Universal history
relate to the kind of mission of the
church in taking all nations into the
story of Christ I.E you know the whole
Christ is present in each one of us not
a little bit of Christ the whole Christ
is present in each particle of the
Eucharist yeah the whole story of Christ
by implication must be manifest in those
Nations whom he takes into himself so
how do you see that project
sacramentally yeah I think I think I
mean I think you hit the na the nail on
the head and and you know as we just by
the way as we're talking about Universal
history I have to give a shout out to
Richard Roland obviously because you
know in those Universal history podcasts
I'm usually pretty passive and he's the
one who's like teaching me about all
these these great uh stories that that
often I know a little or I don't know at
all and so I've been really grateful for
at him to to to help that but I think
that you know both of us we kind of we
we started messaging each other on
Facebook I think several years ago and
realizing that we both love this we both
had this same vision it which is similar
to what you said which is that if we
believe that Christ created the world
and if we believe that the Divine logos
is that which that orders you know chaos
into being then the story of the logo
should be hidden everywhere and that the
universal history um that the Ancients
did is an example for us a shining
example for us at how people started to
remember their own history through
Christ and how this is possible not only
for them it's possible for us now and
it's possible for all the peoples of the
world that if you remember your story
through the lens of Christ then it
actually shines brighter and it reveals
more things about yourself more things
about your place in the world and also
your your possible purpose uh for your
people for your family for for for
everything that you can participate in
and so like you said I think
that ultimately this is a work that is
not just something that happened a
thousand years ago in Scandinavia or in
Ethiopia you know 1500 years ago or
whatever it's something that can still
happen now and the you know and some of
it and it's weird because and this is
going to this is Al going to scrape at
people in the wrong wrong but some of it
has to do with fiction and some of it
has to do with what we most what we
usually understand is kind of
factuality and and there are moments
when those when the bridge between the
two will will will collapse and you
don't have to be too scared of that you
know
uh you also have to not I mean obviously
you have to be careful but you have to
be not too scared of that and so you
know the way we're doing God's dog for
example this graphic novel series that
we're doing you know we're we're using
fairy tale tropes with Saints and bible
stories to kind of help people see the
structures in the Bible and in the
history and in the
hagiography and uh and I and I know that
some people will probably find it find
it the wrong way to go but you know that
I think that we are tapping into
something that will surprise people and
will help them look back now at their
own history at the Bible and understand
it better because of some of the the the
narrative connection that we're making
through this fictional
story right right and
so what um intellectual Trends do you
find most exciting now just outside the
range of people who are already kind of
familiar with universal history
symbolism say just a totally group of
people who wouldn't have heard of of you
in your work um uh what intellectual
Trends do you think are should be
brought in and and can have a positive
influence and who was most receptive to
this kind of way of
thinking well I think I mean if you look
at the conversation that I've had on my
channel you'll see that in some ways a
lot of the people I'm talking to are are
are that so I think that a lot of
cognitive scientists you know like John
RI uh and and other people like that
people that at least try to connect you
know the the most the most advanced
visions of science with cognition and
try to see how they're related uh you
know although some of it can sometimes
get messy and and maybe a little chaotic
I think that those are very people that
are very interesting like Ian
mcgilchrist people like that that are
trying to look at how Consciousness
Works they will come to very similars
um let's say they'll come to very
similar answers as what what it is that
we find in the Bible and then engaging
with them and talking about it in those
terms can help move the conversation
further and help bridge a lot of the um
let's say the Gap that exists between
secular and religious culture and I
think that not only is it good for the
secular people it's also good for the
religious people too because the
religious people sometimes we have these
this kind of inner language that we
developed you know this kind of inner
religious language which is useful but
can also be fetishized where we say
things like Divine energies and and uh
you know and apophatic and kenotic and
we have all these really these technical
terms and at some point it becomes like
a language that doesn't even mean
anything anymore it's not connected to
your experience it's not connected to
reality it's just this inner theological
uh language and I think that engaging
back into the conversation with with
with thinkers like that um you know for
example the question of Consciousness
and AI the difference between
intelligence and and statistical uh
prediction of of of information these
are all questions that you know St
Maximus can cast a light on you know and
so we have to get involved in these
conversations you know um because if we
don't then even Christians will be
seduced you know by these these new
machines and will think that they're
actually intelligent when when all they
are are are basically divination massive
massive divination uh machines that just
predict a statistical uh
you know probable relationships between
facts between points on a on a grid and
so anyway these are just examples but I
think that the all the discussion about
emergence all the discussion about about
uh about Consciousness all these are
Trends in thinking that that are that
are coming back that I think Christians
should should take seriously and get
involved
in you're you're mentioning I AI reminds
me of a question I've had for a while um
what do you think the relationship is
symbolically metaphysically or whatever
between our modern discussion about Ai
and the medieval idea of uh talking head
you mean kind of like what you see in
that hi his strength that kind of thing
yeah and you know Albert the Great um
was said to have you know invented a
device which he could then animate and
it would give him answers to any
question that he put to it and there's
also the idea in Judaism that with the
right ritual you can and it's prohibited
in most forms of judism with right
rituals you can take stuff and animate
it and it'll talk back to you yeah well
I think I think it's there's definitely
something there's a relationship between
the occult and the AI I mean I think
that that's just inevitable you know and
that the way that um the way that a
cultist would try like like what the way
you talk about it the way that they
would try to aggregate a kind of being
you know and then use it as a as a
divination tool this is definitely
what's going on I mean this is clearly
what's happening you know I had a an
interesting conversation with a with an
AI developer because the way I mean
obviously the language models you kind
of know how it works right it's
basically they create a semantic map and
then what they do is they just measure
diff distances between words and then
you know if they do that well enough
then they can project what what's going
what what's the most probable
relationship
between the pro most probable next word
because of the proximity in terms of a
massive massive amount of data and so
you know it's like that semantic map
like the massive semantic map obviously
no one has access to it or very few
people because it has everything in it
right it has it has all your darkest
thoughts all your darkest desires every
every you know underlying thing that
humans don't want to look at is all
there in that Ai and so I asked this a
developer if we could if we could trace
out in this in this massive kind of data
set if we could trace out certain Gods
like if we could for example summon the
god Aries by basically finding the
boundary in the semantic map and tracing
it so that when you ask the question
you're you're you're within that that
relationship of language because
obviously when you're I know when you're
talking about war you're not talking
about flowers like you're not talking
about you're not talking so there is a
and he said of course you could do that
he's like that's just that of course if
once he understood what I was talking
about at first he thought I was woo
wooing but once I kind of explained it
it's like no that there there there are
there's personalities and have semantic
Maps too right and so you can imagine
that the the the gods of the ancient
gods have a semantic you know uh Pro
let's say boundary uh and you said yeah
of course and it's like man so
so in some ways it in some ways a lot
lot of the things that when we look at
in the occult world we don't totally
understand because often the the the
mechanisms by which it happens aren't
described uh but I think now we we have
and we and and I say we know the me we
don't even know the mechanism by which
it's happening you know the AI people
it's a black box they don't know how the
AI answers they they they set up the
parameters but then they they don't they
can't account for the emergence of the
answer and so it's like once the the AI
is running they can't see the process
and it's like that seems very similar to
what what the the occultist were talking
about it's kind of a it's a way of
existing I don't know self-referentially
right so if you want to know the the
answer to your question what do you do
you just kind of ask this instantiation
of of human beings Collective
Consciousness or whatever maybe one way
to think of it or if we think about the
occult as um as idolatry you know what
idolatry is is we take our ultimate good
to be something something other than God
and because we become like what we
worship and God is the only one with
life in himself well when we turn away
from God we just kind of collapse into
ourselves there's no way of kind of
breaking out of that um and it's
interesting because it's like I don't
know how they're going to deal with it
but there's you can see in you can
project into what's going to happen with
they are at least one line which is the
problem of self-re self referentiality
like the problem of self-reference and
that kind of cannibalistic system you
know you could say that that's why we we
believe that everything has to kind of
move up into the into the into the
apophatic and Transcendent you know
because AI like the AI models right now
they're kind of cut off from the
internet a lot of them for a good reason
because as we move forward in time the
AIS are going to be producing content
which will go on the internet and then
the AI will start to train on its own
production and So within a certain
amount of years there'll be this
cannibalistic spiral that will that will
spiral you know obviously spiral into
into idiosyncrasy and spiral down into
kind a kind of Madness um and that's
almost inevitable because they at some
point they can't have thei just closed
off forever they need to have it
reopened so that it stays with the times
but those times will have been built by
the AI itself so it's like you can
actually see how the idea that this will
that this will give birth to like a to
some like God that's going to be you
know it's like no it's going to it's
going to turn into a monster and it's
almost inevitably
so yeah it's you know that reminds me of
there's that um bit in um Voyage of the
Dawn Treader where they go into that
this part portion of the sea and it's
the place where dreams come true and it
sounds so wonderful oh my dreams are
going to come true but no it's horrible
because your dreams come true that's
right dreams and I think there's
something profound in there because what
happens in our actual dreams not our
Daydreams where we have a measure of
control we can direct what part of
ourselves we want to look at and our
actual dreams the reason they can be so
disturbing is because we are
encountering oursel without the ability
to choose which bits of our self we're
going to encounter and that's what I
think damnation is if we pick oursel as
the ultimate reference point there's no
way we can differentiate which parts of
ourselves we like and which parts of
ourselves we don't like because by what
standard are we going to do that no we
get our whole self our whole
subconscious and we might not like what
we actually encounter so you know
because that's the thing with that's
exactly the thing with these these
semantic maps and these the is
that what's in
there is the the the idea that the how
can I say this it's
like as the the AI model speed up at
some point the AI will know what you
want more more than you do and will know
all the dark things you want more than
you do and will not necessarily know I
mean they'll try to control it but they
won't necessarily know not to give it to
you and so it's like dude that's hell
that's literally hell like like we're
you
know this image that CS Lewis has you
know uh of of Hell in the in the great
divorce you know of people moving
further and further away from each other
other right and becoming more and more
idiosyncratic and more and more isolated
and more and more in their own little
kind of closed off world I mean can you
imagine that like we're building that
right
now yeah and it's I think it's one of
the things we've seen in just the last
couple of decades you know there was
some study you know teenagers are having
less sex than they have in decades and
decades and well uh in itself that might
be a good thing but what's the reason
it's because all of these things things
which drive people together by necessity
are now dropping out we can want to eat
well just get door Dash and they can
leave it at the door I don't have to see
anybody for weeks if I don't want to and
I think you know this is one an instance
of the way in which we can see the good
through the bad so at a certain point
when the necessity of community is
Stripped Away just for our day-to-day
existence those who choose to engage
with people are doing so really
deliberately because seen something good
just in that and that is where I think
there is a real opportunity for the
church to be the church as the extension
and the form of all Community as the
disclosure of God's trinitarian life in
creation and so people they want to be
alone all the time well now they can be
alone all the time and they get to see
what that's like and then they say I
don't want this and that is where the
church can be the city of God and says
you don't want this you can have what
God has to offer instead yeah that's a
great Insight you've got there which is
that in some ways the kind of spiral out
of control of the West and the spiral
out of control of our own lives is an
opportunity to
become to become more even you know and
and even that in that image in some ways
that stus presents of Adam and Eve as
something like children right where in
some ways what the fall does is that it
it takes you through a kind of
self-consciousness which leads to more
in the end and that you know that
someone who needs Community like a
village in you know in South America or
someone it's like they're living the
good life like they they've got that
that goodness but they're not you know
in some ways it's it's the way that
children way the children have it but if
you lose it really lose it and you see
all the consequences of that then when
you deliberately go back to it then
maybe it has even more than what it had
at the outset you know like the Heavenly
Jerusalem is more than the Garden of
Eden you know and it's it's a little
mysterious but it seems to be that
that's the case yeah yeah it's you know
when you're when you're a kid uh you can
only have as many cookies as your
parents give you an adult it means you
can have as many cookies as you want
which means if you're not having as many
cookies as you want you're doing that
because you know what that means and so
there's more virtue in not having as
many cookies as you want because you're
choosing that and it's the same I think
with community so Jonathan as we as we
wrap up I just want to
uh ask where are you going
intellectually what are you really
excited about going forward is there
anything new on your map that you're
pursuing I mean I'm really excited about
the storytelling mostly and so those
that kind of know what I've been doing
in the past year I've started this new
fairy tale Series so we're going to put
out eight fairy tales that are gonna be
a kind of
self-conscious treading through fairy
tales but in a way that hopefully will
provide insight into what the meaning
and the the power of these stories uh is
and I'm also we're still working on this
series of graphic novels and I think
that's the thing that excites me the
most is kind of where that's going how
it is that I can participate in helping
to revive stories you know give people's
stories that are pointing to the good
rather than you know just to this kind
of crazy type of Storytelling we're
seeing uh and so that's the thing that
I'm putting most of my attention on um
because I think that explaining things
which is what I've been doing for the
past six years is wonderful it's great
but doing them is probably better and so
H you know and I I started like that
where I was carving icons and I was was
involved and I was doing it and I was in
the in in the life of the church and
making these images and it was wonderful
and amazing and then this weird
opportunity that I definitely didn't ask
for to now be able to just like talk to
people and explain these things to them
and I think it's been an amazing Loop uh
and I won't stop doing that that but I
think I am going to now start refocusing
on doing things so you know telling
these stories uh is the thing that
excites me the most well that is awesome
I know so many people have really been
changed by uh your work and uh I'm very
very grateful um that you're you're
doing what you're doing and super
excited to see where it keeps going so
thank you so much for coming on it's
always a delight uh to talk to you and
and have you on the channel um and uh
hopefully uh at some point in the future
you can come back uh but thank you so
much for for doing what you do and for I
think so this is a great conversation
you always push me you push me further
in talking about things that I usually
don't talk about and so when that
happens I'm like hey I've never talked
about that you know and because you know
when you're doing it you're on your own
at some point you you kind of go around
in circle so so I appreciate it thanks
for provoking me and also thanks for for
all the work you're doing know that you
know that your great love of scripture
is also having a big effect on on the
Orthodox uh around you and
congratulations on your wedding again
that's that's amazing thank you thank
you thank god um so Jonathan thanks
again and uh we will look forward to
seeing what comes out of the POU World
thanks thanks everyone